I am so excited to be sitting here with
Roy Hibbert from the Indiana Pacers one
of the most incredible centers
point-guard Center all-time all-time one
of the greatest basketball players a lot
number one number one alive Succot
LeBron I don't know anything ever block
LeBron yes does that I mean you just
think about that when you having a blue
day I would what are the common tall guy
questions cuz you're 7 7 - 7 - yeah but
when I stood up you said I wasn't that
I'm 6 6 that's not that bad no I mean
that's pretty good
you're like a civilian oh regulars
normies normies movies buckles I won't
say muggles but you know oh yeah I may
get a lot of questions like how's the
air up there and I'm like it's the same
as down there yeah we just get it first
you're welcome
you're amazing how's that feel Oh being
amazing and um
yours was younger I did but uh I'm
dating Oh Oh a white woman and she
doesn't like that she's not in like the
tucking your shirt into your khakis type
of thing where did you meet this woman
Marilyn illiterate George tell George
now oh you went to college together yeah
and what is it public what her name is
oh I like to keep it you know hello
people she sounds like a Cheryl no I
mean she's a very nice woman Britney no
Sarah no Julie no Meredith we can keep
going no no Suzanna no Anna Marie
I'm just trying to think of some real
uptight white girl names I saw you on
the Kroll show I was on the college and
I like okay you tell that guy said hello
you're also friends with Chelsea Freddie
she's my homegirl yes you know yes
that's awesome
yes I love her to death yeah and she's
the worst not offensive I will put you
who speak ill about well you know what I
mean she's so good at breaking balls and
cutting people down yeah one of my
favorite people in the world she can
also be hilariously you know cutting in
her own way yeah we were like real cool
friends you know I give her tickets
whenever I went to LA I said and she
she'd she'd be performing in some some
town in Indiana I'd drive an hour and a
half out to greet her and everything
like that and and anna-marie would come
with me then she got on Brooklyn
nine-nine yeah she blows up yeah that's
like one that gets an award and she just
forgets all about me she hasn't like I'm
a little person like I'm six six you did
Parks and Rec uh-huh you were with his
ease Aziz is a nice guy I love is easy
can you do is easy I can do is ease well
the closest I can get to Aziz we have
the same skin skin tone that's right so
that's the closest oh I win so if it's a
skin impression yeah you wanna guess his
name is Michael it's a country in Africa
jahmai Oh Kenya yep you ever just
instinctually block stuff like you're at
a party until I was like here's my keys
and it's coming on this other guy yeah
yeah Utah was coming with the right
button I came with the left those are
the questions for Shaq yeah I like Shaq
he's a good man he's a very large man
dude huge you know like if I were in the
Star Wars movie and you know when he
opened up that Camel looking thing I
could probably fit ya inside of Shaq and
stay warm and I bet for these
coordinates you have like a signature
move
like you block a shot maybe so I don't I
don't I've been working on it I've been
thinking about stuff for a while yeah
what's like what's what do you work
shopping I don't like your ecstasy in a
rave
that's good like confuse it like do
another sport
I mean like I don't want to come to
games we're doing some fool in but I
actually think that'd be pretty funny
what if you Swan it and then and then
you go like look your journaling about
it later
yeah I was gonna go in Doogie Howser but
I love you you went right to carry
watches shows you beautiful women Gavin
drinking mimosas that'd be dumb there
Tuesday is nothing else paying attention
I played you in a video game we're good
- Kay I guess would have been 13 oh good
Jukka NBA 2k13 do you feel weird that
I've been alone in my house manipulating
your body
Oh strangely he's okay with it more
because he's cool because we're like
didn't stop it
it's still happening this was awesome
man thank you so much for taking the
time to talk
Roy Hibbert we're gonna be friends
[Applause]
[Music]